З пустель Саудівської Аравії
до вулиць країн західної Африки.
І в коридорах Білого дому.
Через телебачення, радіо, онлайн і соціальні мережі.
Інтернаціональна команда журналістів Deutsche Welle
інформує мільйони людей  по цілій планеті
на тридцяти мовах світу, в тому числі й українською.
65 років тому Deutsche Welle вперше вийшла в ефір -
3 травня 1953 року,
символічно в Всесвітній день свободи преси.
Тоді бюро було розташоване в західнонімецькому Кельні.
Перші передачі вийшли німецькою мовою на коротких хвилях.
Цільовою групою були німці за кордоном.
Згодом з'явилися передачі іноземними мовами.
Зведення Берлінського муру 1961 року
посилило роль Deutsche Welle як голосу західної демократії.
Слухачі за "залізною завісою" використовували DW
як джерело неупереджених новин.
Люди були ізьоловані, їм не дозволяли подорожувати.
Вони жили під ковпаком постійного страху та напруги
і слухали всі закордонні телерадіоканали.
Не лише Deutsche Welle. Але Deutsche Welle мала зразкову репутацію.
З падінням Берлінського муру і возз’єднанням Німеччини
розпочалася нова ера для Deutsche Welle.
У 1992 році стартували
телеефіри DW через супутник.
На початку телеканал DW виходив в ефір 6 годин на день
німецькою та англійською мовами для глядачів у Європі.
Політичні потрясіння на зміні століть
принесли ще більше реформ телекомпанії.
Після війни в Афганістані DW допомагала
відновити там медійний ландшафт.
Для посилення діалогу з арабським світом
DW запустила телевійзійні програми арабською.
Сьогодні програма Shabab Talk стала однією з найуспішніших у регіоні.
Близько трьох тисяч працівників з понад шістдесяти країн світу
нині працюють на Deutsche Welle - у Бонні та Берліні.
А також у різних куточках світу.
Українська редакція DW почала роботу
у березні 2000 року. Спершу як радіо на коротких хвилях,
згодом на перший план вийшов інтернет.
Після Майдану DW значно розширила свою діяльність в Україні:
відкрила кореспондентський пункт у Києві,
почала виробляти телепрограми українською мовою
та активізувала свою присутність в соцмережах.
Спільноти DW українською на Facebook, Twitter та YouTube
нині налічують загалом понад 185 тисяч фоловерів.